[Musique]
jour j pour quelques centaines de jeunes
à travers la france il découvre
aujourd'hui la caserne dans laquelle ils
vont passer un an au 92ème régiment
d'infanterie à clermont ferrand
l'incorporation comment ce premier
contact avec le service militaire que
l'on pourrait diviser en trois périodes
cette première journée donc les deux
mois de classes et les dix derniers mois
en unités richard laurent est originaire
de martigues
jean philippe garcia de cournon ils
viennent d'être placés dans un petit
groupe d'une dizaine d'hommes ils vont
avec eux de déshabillage en formalité
suivre la chaîne d'incorporation
ils reçoivent tout de suite l'insigne du
régiment et leurs premières soldes 315
francs un petit encouragement avant de
passer chez le coiffeur des coiffeuses
en l'occurrence au 92e puisque les
demoiselles de l'école de coiffure de
clermont viennent tous les deux mois
réaliser la première coupe d appeler un
moyen d'accomplir dans un sourire cette
opération attendue avec appréhension
mais aussi d'éviter une trop longue
attente avant de poursuivre la chaîne
est de mettre le cap sur un autre poste
l'infirmerie en l'occurrence viendra
ensuite la distribution du paquetage l'a
l'appelée va recevoir les vêtements et
accessoires qu'il devra conserver
pendant un an
83 juste avant le repas un diabo sera
projeté aux jeunes recrues il présente
l'historique du 92e mais aussi comment
va se dérouler cette année qu'ils vont
vivre dans ses murs vous allez voir la
diapo son vous représentant différentes
phases de mon incorporation et de votre
service national vous allez recevoir une
formation de combattants individuel donc
un entraînement à la marche marche
progressive bien sûr de 8 10 15 km qui
seront
acheminé pour arriver à un exercice de
synthèse dit fourragères cdh ensuite
l'heure du repas autre découverte celle
de l'ordinaire richard jean philippe et
les autres marques aux murs des affiches
qui les renseignent sur le prix de
revient de ce repas des affiches qui
leur recommande de ne gaspillez ni la
nourriture ni les couverts sera ensuite
l'heure du repos et les apprentis
guerriers vont rejoindre leurs chambres
est-ce que vous avez l'appréhension ce
matin 21 peu j'étais un peu perdue
achètent quand je serai ici là on
connaît pas du tout le bâtiment
ça commence à aller un peu mieux pour la
journée ça commence à perdre des vies on
verra bien ça fait déjà eu le temps de
rencontrer des champions
des connaissances dans notre antenne par
section fait que entre jeunes sont à 8
est ce que vous savez ce qui vous attend
dans les prochains mois on nous a
vaguement parlé on risque d'aller en
campagne combat ou en compagnie de deux
soutiens d'éclairage qu'est ce qui vous
ennuie le plus quand vous pensez à ces
douze mois que ça allait passer ici mais
ce qui m'a le plus moi c'est d'être loin
de chez moi pour trouver du bon copain
quand même pas finir l'armée parce que
l'un joue à l'erdre une bonne
camaraderie et les élans s'entendent
bien la séance comme les anciens alors
passionnante ailleurs problème la
camaraderie un mot qui revient souvent
dans les propos des hommes du 92ème
régiment d'infanterie ils sont 1500
total à se regrouper sous l'emblème du
gaulois
parmi eux 12 cents combattants et 300
hommes en instruction le 92e comprend en
effet une compagnie de commandement et
des services trois compagnies de combat
et un groupement d'instruction
la grande majorité du contingent est
originaire de la région en effet ce
régiment qui descend en double filiation
du royal italien et du walsh irlandais
puissent les forces dans cette terre
auvergnate où il s'est installé voici
tout juste cent ans
et si le régiment se tourner vers son
passé à l'occasion de ce centenaire il
reste résolument actuelle ne serait ce
que par son armement
en matériel ça représente plus d'une
centaine de vab
ce sont des véhicules de l'avant blindé
ces grosses bêtes que vous avez vu
rouler dans le quartier ça représente
des armes
un armement antichar extrêmement
considérable il ya vingt-quatre mille
ans qui sont des missiles antichars
capable détruire tous les chars à 2000
mètres plus de 70 et les races et qui
sont des lance roquettes capables de
détruire tous les chars à 500 m est
également 4 mortiers de 120 8 mortier de
80 des radars détecteurs de personnel
avec des oliphant ça fait donc un
matériel extrêmement considérable appelé
passe une année où 92e qu'est ce que
cette année peut leur apporter
je pense que c'est une année
enrichissante dans leur vie d'une part
sur le plan militaire bien sûr
puisqu'ils sont là pour ça et là
vraiment on apprend en faire des
combattants rapidement des gens capables
de tenir leur place il y avait un combat
à mener et sur le plan personnel c'est
une année très riche en contacts car
évidemment il ya un brassage de tous les
milieux il y a une vie collective qu'ils
ne connaissaient pas auparavant il y a
une vie sportive également et je pense
que sur le plan camaraderie savez les
camarades conçu avait atteint dans un
régiment son second garde pour la vie
bien c'est toujours vrai aujourd'hui
on dit souvent dans le peuple que
l'armée fait des hommes est ce que c'est
toujours vrai abce avait heureusement
qu'ils arrivent en étant un peu membres
et mais enfin quand même nous
développons leurs qualités sportives
leurs qualités collectives localité de
résistance également leurs
responsabilités
on développe énormément leur sens de
responsabilité et je pense qu'ils
sortent de là un peu plus des garcia 11e
compagnie troisième section aux autres
sergents propos connaissez votre tag and
pay day 2 mettez là une paix s'il vous
plaît pour l'instruction les hommes
quittent le quartier les manoeuvres se
font en effet à la fontaine du berger ou
canton lastic les hommes regroupés par
deux effectué ici un rallye feta ces
binômes met en pratique sur le terrain
ce qu'on leur a appris
ils répètent les gestes à accomplir ici
en cas d'attaqué nbc entendez nucléaire
biologique chimique
un exercice qui n'exclut pas la
préparation à
des combats plus traditionnelle lm
gradés fournier 92e régiment
d'infanterie 12e compagnie section
lieutenant pousse à vous en même temps
le codevi gros 92e régiment d'infanterie
et 12e compagnie section du lieutenant
pousse fabricants non et non
bien vous êtes en ambiance combat vous
arrivez déplacer en tête de patrouille
vous arrivez au point nous sommes votre
chef de patrouille vous dit vous allez
effectuer un déplacement jusqu'à l'arbre
en boule qui situe dans la direction de
nombre à environ 250 mètres
ou bar où quand comment bien en
appliquant ces quatre questions vous
allez maintenant choisir votre
itinéraire et effectuer le déplacement
je vous regarde faire
rappel vous êtes en ambiance combat vous
prenez donc vos armes à la main
[Musique]
oui
à l'issue de ces deux mois de classe se
déroule la fourragère pour le roi garcia
elle va se dérouler au calvin et dans le
cantal
une cérémonie qui va marquer la fin de
l'instruction et la ventilation ouvert
une section au sein de laquelle ils vont
occuper un travail pendant dix mois
[Musique]
cette cérémonie marquera une étape
importante à la fois de votre service
militaire
également dans vos responsabilités de
citoyens étape importante de votre
service militaire
car désormais vous n'êtes plus de jeunes
recrues à l'instruction
mais des soldats à part entière qu'est
ce qui vous a semblé le plus difficile
au cours de ces derniers mois mais
surtout les deux premiers mois les
classes séparées les classes pour
richard jean philippe se sont maintenant
dix mois de routine avant la libération
une quarantaine de semaine ponctuée par
les permissions avec pour quotidien le
tir pour l'un et un camion pour l'autre
[Musique]